thank you for clicking on this video I
don't know what the thumbnail was but I
suppose it might have been catchy in
either case thanks for coming back
letting you know right out the gate this
video is brought to you by raycon I'm
gonna talk about that a little later but
first funny and also true story going
into this movie I knew nothing about it
at all except it dealt with food the
fine dining experience I was like all
right let's do it let's get our food
pouring on
holy [ __ ]
so the menu is directed by Mark my Lodge
Stars Anya Taylor Joy Ray finds you also
have the likes of Nicholas Holt and John
leg was ammo in here and the premise is
there's this restaurant this fine dining
experience on this little island the
kind of fine dining experience that very
few people will ever actually get to
experience in their lives so a group of
people consisting of Foodies food
critics wealthy folks and the like they
all go to this island to experience this
restaurant I'm watching the movie and
all the dishes are completely gorgeous
it has the breakdown of what the dish is
on the side of the screen every serving
I was like if this is the movie I'm
totally down some character dialogue and
some good food what's not to like
seriously I was totally down for that
and then you're like is everything okay
with this place and then the movie ends
up becoming a thriller what I like about
that really it's me talking about what I
liked about the trailer the trailer
shows the vibe that the movie is a
thriller but it's also incredibly vague
as the how thank you trailer to the menu
for Not spoiling the film but getting
the atmosphere of it you know but
trailers should do now I'm going to tell
you something this is going to be the
most incredibly obvious thing you will
ever hear in the history of your life
you ready for it you ready to feel like
Captain Barbosa here we go Anya Taylor
joy and Roy finds are incredible in this
film yes we know that one anything else
right how else would they be but Ray
finds as the egocentric Chef he's like
the kind of Chef that Bradley Cooper in
burnt dreams of being like and after
that can maintain that kind of
mysterious intensity also have a couple
of funny moments that don't compromise
the tension I need to explain that
because when someone says oh this movie
has some funny moments I had a good
chuckle it's easy to hear it had that
humor that's really forced and
compromises any and all tension in the
scene no not here this movie had some
great dark humor I got a good chuckle
also tension remain now this is a film
that takes place largely for most of the
movie in this one room in this one
dining area in this one restaurant I
love a movie that can pull that off when
a movie can pull that off happy to say
the menu does it's a more intimate
setting it's a setting that uses the
premise of the film to its advantage and
I'd be remiss if I didn't mention the
fact that there is social commentary
going on in here too and his commentary
that mixes well and is easily
palatable
you know what I mean just all made sense
you know another thing I liked about
this film when it comes to it being a
thriller is that the restaurant the fine
dining experience the menu the meals the
chef all of it was always front and
center it was all part of the brick and
mortar of the film usually a thriller
about people in a restaurant will start
out in the restaurant but the restaurant
itself the dining experience just kind
of gets forgotten now you're just in a
building where everyone is now this is
me trying to think of all the Thrillers
that I've seen that take place in a
restaurant but you know what I mean you
know what I'm saying usually whatever
building the characters are in just
reverts to being a building and the
Thriller is some external Force but in
here I was really impressed that the
dining experience was always front and
center in a world where most movies have
those logic leaps you have to take this
movie does have a couple where I was
like well I didn't by the end you know
am I buying all of it
not necessarily but by the end I didn't
care I was having that much fun with it
and that's really the trick of Cinema is
to have the audience enjoy a film so
much that they don't care the leaps I
will say the early dialogue in the movie
you know me I don't give a [ __ ] about
cursing just as a concept in general but
I also don't like lazy dialogue in
movies and early in this film there are
so many f-bombs in quick succession in
the first few minutes it came across as
lazy it irons itself out at a point and
that goes away it just makes me scratch
my head like did you have to make sure
all of these f-bombs were in the
beginning so the movie was just
guaranteed to be rated R because rated R
makes a movie feel cooler but in the end
the menu was a damn good time it's my
favorite kind of good time too it
usually happens with Thrillers that
movie I don't know much about I watch it
turns out to be a satisfying Thriller
great acting solid tension the film has
so much fun with his [ __ ] up premise
that you can't help but have fun as well
I feel like if you like a good thriller
a solid Thriller in general you'll enjoy
yourself but if you're you're a foodie
who likes fine cuisine also you happen
to like a thriller this movie was made
for you it's as simple as this when you
know doing what I do sometimes you talk
about a movie
and it just feels like work you're like
I movie wasn't fun
let's clock on watching and talking
about this movie nothing but a good time
this one's worth watching and worth
buying on Blu-ray and as I mentioned
earlier this video is brought to you by
raycon headphones this time I know plot
twist blows the mind doesn't it raycon's
with her wireless earbuds headphones and
speakers offer a premium sound a
comfortable fit and up to 54 hours of
battery life I bring this to you because
as the holidays are upon us the gift
giving season is here you might be
looking for gift ideas we all know
Gamers or music lovers good folks who
just want to put on their headphones and
ignore humans also the raycon website
offers buy now pay later options and I
really appreciate that and raycon
started about half the price of other
premium Brands so click the link in the
description go to buy recon.com enter
promo code early BF does it stand for
best friends maybe get 20 off site-wide
with that route or you can save even
more get 30 off when you shop recon's
holiday bundles alright so the menu have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's a movie that is a thriller
that you didn't know was a thriller when
you went into it you're like oh this is
math how's it ever happened to you
whatever the movie whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]